[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on sockin super
excited to be talking about cell free
molecular discovery very excited to have
dr. Luis Metzger joining us on the show
hello
really excited to be here thanks el and
think solution went on very pumped very
pumped this is the edge of biotech we're
gonna be talking about that we're
talking about your journey very excited
for those that don't know lewis's
background he initially did a PhD at
Duke in biochemistry then he went on
into the postdoc at UCSF then he became
a principal scientist at Novartis for
about six years
discovering novel antibiotics then most
recently he's been a year with as the
chief scientific officer at Terra
Biosciences where he's doing cell free
synthetic biology searching for
molecules I'm very very excited to be
talking about this and so much more you
know there's so much more in the
background as well it's all in the bio
ok Luis we'd like to start things off
with this big history perspective on
civilization what is your current take
on the synthesis of the human experiment
well I mean it's it's these are the best
of times in some ways and they're scary
and dangerous times in other ways but I
I would say we're in an interesting
place because I don't think that
humanity has fundamentally changed in
its desires and motivations for
thousands of years our technology has
certainly changed and one perspective I
have is that we're at the point where we
can precisely engineer biology now to be
clear
people have humanity has been
engineering its world for you know
millennia
I mean hunting you know megafauna to
extinction you know changing you know
the very the very nature of the land
that they live in and also doing genetic
experiments with low
so look at all the breeds of dogs that
we have today you know that is the
result of human selection and you know
engineering of biology as it were and
farm animals and crops and everything
else so but now we're at this point
everyone you we've many people have
heard about CRISPR and numerous other
technologies that allow us to precisely
engineer biology and I think that's
going to be the hallmark of the coming
century I think if we had you know an
industrial revolution a silicon
revolution those revolutions have set up
a biological revolution and I think that
this is this is an interesting time to
live and at the same time I think that
we humanity oscillates especially with
modern communications between being
pulled closer together in some ways and
you know other forces trying to move
people into tribes so it's easier to
find your tribe on social media or in
the workplace or wherever you look for
your tribe and it's easier to
communicate with people than ever but in
many ways perhaps because of that we're
more isolated than ever in some ways and
more connected in others so it's all
these objectives you know these these
these opposites that we have are make
this time really interesting and I hope
I hope that humanity can traverse this
period and and find sort of a humanistic
outcome for for people for instance all
of this automation that that we see in
biology in
in in so many other areas does
eventually eliminate certain types of
jobs but it creates others and is
humanity going to reach some sort of
technical singularity where we can take
care of everyone give people a good
quality of life and then what does what
does wealth look like in that situation
is it freedom to be creative to have
that sort of most limiting resource time
so anyway my take on humanity is that we
can engineer everything better and
better we're entering a time where you
know we we reach a point where humanity
can probably provide for its needs if it
finds a way to do so that doesn't leave
anyone behind and so I think that's
that's the risk that goes along with the
benefit of how we're evolving this is a
100 trillion dollar opportunity as we've
been circulating in the media now with
it in the bio article and stuff it's
very exciting what biotechnology and the
engineering of everything that our world
actually is made of can potentially
bring in civilizational flourishing as
super exciting I'm glad you really are
so passionate about that and we're gonna
break down a lot of these regards in
terms of like this scientifically
foundation of scientific knowledge we're
going to talk about that later as well
I'm really excited
ok take us down the the kind of like
your your a little bit about the
childhood what got you into biotech what
got you into what you were doing at Duke
and what not take us through that so I
don't know some of the people who are
watching this may have read a book by
Oliver Sacks
I think it's called uncle tungsten and
it among other things it makes the point
of how childhood chemistry sets can be
useful for me it was actually a kid's
microscope set that my parents bought me
for I don't know my fifth or sixth or
seventh birthday a long time ago or so
it seems and they are not scientists my
but they're very bright people who had a
great love of nature and you know we
grew up in the desert Southwest so we
went on hikes we you know we we really
were encouraged to explore and I think
that that that whet my appetite for not
only could we observe interesting things
through telescopes on the you know the
sort of the large end of the scale but
we could observe things that were
invisible under microscopes and there
was all this biology and chemistry
happening all around us that we can't
even see without special equipment and
so I think that microscope did that for
me
but in addition to that I I went to a
public high school I really really had a
good time there
it was Cibolo High School in Albuquerque
New Mexico and I had to - I have many
teachers who influenced me quite a bit
and one was Bonnie Crumpler a biologist
and really got me interested in genetics
and how genes made proteins or encoded
proteins and how those did chemistry and
I really liked chemistry you know in
those original classes that I took so I
thought well can I find a career that
you know a source area of study that
combines biology and chemistry and so
biochemistry does although it means so
many different things ranging from
molecular biology to you know mainly
enzyme catalyzed reactions and
everything in between and so that was a
direction I wanted to go in undergrad I
considered being a pre-med but really
stuck with the trajectory towards
research science I don't think you'd
want me to be your physician because I
might say oh can we leave that control
to Marin to see how you know how
everything's working so you might the
medical work was probably not what I was
cut out for but but I wanted to have an
impact and engineering biology studying
biochemistry as a way to do that so it's
kind of where I've come from and what
what got me started
a reoccurring theme for the guests that
we feature on the show is that there is
a mentor or influence of sorts all the
way from the childhood bio chemistry
sets microscopes etc all the way to your
biology teacher in high school also
being a major catalyst for your interest
as well this is really important these
are the ways that we can help unlock the
full potential in the youth across the
world is to have these mentorships have
these risks these opportunities these
doors
open up for people have them really
pursue them okay let's go to how did the
interest get you into your you know your
PhD and into what you were doing in your
postdoc work like tell us about that
part so I when I was an undergrad I did
a few things that gave me some
perspective I worked at nights at a
clinical reference laboratory so that
that sounds exciting but it really
involved centrifuging people's blood
samples and and aliquot and urine
samples and things like that and making
sure that labels matched on test tubes
but it was actually an interesting
window into the medical field and well I
had a good time working there and it
actually was a good nighttime undergrad
compatible job it made me think not sure
I really want to go into the medical
profession but it made me think a lot
about cell biology and biochemistry
because in essence that's what you know
clinical laboratories do on these
specimens and at the same time I did
undergraduate work in computational
chemistry so computational simulation of
small molecules binding to proteins and
causing them to change how they do their
chemistry and that was with David
Vanderjagt at the University of New
Mexico and as I was wrapping up entering
my senior year I had this dilemma that I
think many undergrads have was you know
go into grad school you know apply to
med school you know do something else
and for better or worse I decided to
apply to graduate schools and I didn't
know how competitive I would be so I
applied to various tiers and then ended
with a lot of interviews I really liked
Duke I thought their biochemistry
department had very interesting research
and at the time a professor who is chair
of the department Christian Reitz who
ended up being my thesis advisor had me
do an extra interview during my visit to
Duke with him and I had no idea I would
later join his lab but there was this
infectious enthusiasm for science that
he had and he loaded me down with
reprints of his papers yeah way too many
to read and I had this big stack of
reprints that I took home on the
airplane and I ended up going there
ended up working for him and ended up
traversing this interesting area from
going to essentially theoretically
thinking about biochemistry from a you
know computational docking approach to
actually working with the proteins in
the lab and for me that that was an
eye-opener because it's it's one thing
to model things it's another thing to do
the wet lab experiments and so I really
appreciated that chance and I must admit
I wasn't that good at it at first I had
to get my you know pipette hands yeah
working and and and and and really
there's there's a science to that sort
of work but there's also an art and I
think that that's perhaps
underappreciated so that's how I how I
ended up in graduate school I actually
didn't join my thesis advisors lab and
originally I joined the lab of an x-ray
crystallographer because I specifically
wanted to learn how to determine the
molecular structures of proteins where
all the atoms are or likely are in these
molecular models that I'd used in
computational docking it turns out the
professor whose lab I joined was denied
tenure probably for political reasons
not because of productivity or science
and so after a year I had to switch to
another laboratory and the guy who was
loaded me down with reprints of his
papers Chris rates convinced me to to
give a try at working in his lab and he
did work on among other things bacterial
membrane by
Genisys so how do bacteria make the
coating on them that separates the
outside environment from the inside and
if you think about that that's how I got
towards antibiotic so oh cool that's a
good link yeah that's a good link to
that okay so bacterial membrane
biogenesis yeah very interesting so okay
now your this is also cool how you had
this both up like a computational
chemistry side and then also a a hands
in with the protein and enzyme sort of
manufacturing side of of things within
the lab as well I thought that was that
was good I'm I'm I'm trying to I'm
trying to like I'm trying to take my
like kindergarten understanding of
biology and trying up it up to first and
second grade over the next like like
couple of years if I can if I can get to
a better understanding of the central
dogma of biology and I think if we can
better teach more young people about the
central dogma of biology and then get
them to make it applicable in the
biotech engineering fields that we have
this is gonna help with that this
hundred trillion dollar opportunity okay
so now teach us about how that
transition happened with Novartis as you
were saying with the bacterial membrane
biogenesis and stuff so so I I did work
in graduate school that characterized
some of the enzymes the proteins that do
chemistry that wear that chemistry was
necessary for bacteria to make their
membranes and all cells have membranes
and they separate the chemistry that
happens inside the cell from whatever's
going on on the outside and it's really
one of the defining features of life
because it it's it contains these
self-perpetuating chemical reactions and
so you have to have a division of
outside versus inside and membranes
which are usually made mostly of lipids
you know perform that role they perform
that that separation function so that's
what I you know I learned about that in
grad school and I went and did a postdoc
at UCSF
and I had an opportunity to work with
Robert Stroud a very productive
crystallographer and was able to solve
the crystal structure of one of the
enzymes that I discovered in grad school
so I did eventually get to do x-ray
crystallography just not when and where
I thought I would and I remember how
exciting it was when we collected the
data sets up on Berkeley Hill up at LBL
the particle accelerator up there and I
remember getting a data set that I knew
would be good enough to finally write up
the work and publish and the Sun was
rising over you know it was an all-night
shift at the at the synchotron and and
then you know I wandered outside to take
a coffee break and the Sun was rising
and I thought oh good this is we have a
full story here but you know so I'd
always stayed I stayed a bit with this
theme of memory and biogenesis and
enzymes that you work on lipids and I my
postdoc was a little under two years in
my field postdocs are taking longer and
longer and we can talk about that maybe
later because I don't think it's a good
thing but the time came for me to decide
what to do next and I could have stayed
as a postdoc for much longer and work on
some projects that I had cooking in the
lab on you know other proteins but I had
an opportunity to interview at Novartis
Novartis is a Swiss company big pharma
company but it has it's infectious
diseases program in or did have its
infectious diseases program in
Emeryville California and had just moved
to that site in 2011 it's infectious
disease program moved from Cambridge
Massachusetts to Emeryville so they were
hiring up and for me it was a very lucky
thing because I could still be a postdoc
now but I was in the right place at the
right time and was lucky enough to get
brought onto the team there and and and
then among other things I supported
antibiotic discovery projects I founded
one project which I ultimately led and
participated in many others and also did
tech devel
and and discoveries so especially in the
areas of protein chemistry and you know
in that process it was fun I got to be
both a principal investigator in a
disease area that I'd studied and really
care about which is antibiotic discovery
which I think we desperately need and at
the same time I got to learn all these
other things about biology about fungal
diseases about oncology and Pharma
because the department I was in
supported all of those and was really a
great six years I enjoyed it and you
know my group my former group will be
publishing our work so you probably know
that Novartis pulled the plug on its
infectious diseases programs last June
or July I believe and a few months after
I left and the good news however is a
lot of that work will be published so
people will be able to follow on and
unbilled upon what we did there so yeah
so that's kind of how my work evolved
into the ID world this is yeah there's
that other connecting link which is the
discovery you were working on antibiotic
discovery and now it's again this the
cell-free minute Molecular discovery so
on the give us a quick bit on the
antibiotic discovery as we get into the
next one just she's just about kind of
like what is exactly the cutting edge of
that field well it's it's both cutting
edge there's things that are cutting
edge and there's things that are pretty
old-fashioned I mean in the end of the
day you need compounds that kill the
bacteria that you're after
first and foremost and I guess supposed
to put it bluntly those same compounds
can't kill or badly injure the patient
and good stuff the good stuff the good
stuff and so you know in its first
principle what you're trying to do is
take bacteria treat them with molecules
many molecules millions individually if
possible and see to those molecules kill
the bacteria and if the answer is yes
then you do those experiments more
carefully sometimes you figure out why
they're killing the bacteria sometime
you never know exactly what the
mechanism is and then eventually you
have to find out if the molecule it's
toxic to all types of cells and that
would include animal cells or human
cells than animal studies than human
safety studies than human efficacy
studies studies so sort of the normal
progression of drug discovery but
starting with bacteria and sometimes
those projects didn't start with the
bacteria sometimes they started with an
enzyme or a group of enzymes that we
knew did essential chemistry for
bacteria that did not have equivalents
in humans because if you're thinking of
developing a drug that's an
antibacterial it's best maybe to search
for ways to mess up the chemistry that
the bacteria do but that humans don't
have an equivalent process because then
you're less likely to find compounds
that are toxic to humans and and that
was always the difficulty so finding
those molecules and and this really
leads into what I'm doing now so what we
what we found in Big Pharma antibiotic
discovery antibacterial discovery all of
all of Big Pharma's efforts do involve
four on one hand screening of biologics
and antibodies and I'm sure many of the
viewers know about that but not not all
organisms can be targeted with biologics
there's been some work targeting
bacteria with biologics and with things
called phages but still if you look at
the antibiotics that we use there are
small molecules that have to get into
the bacteria they get inside they mess
up the bacterias biochemistry they kill
the bacteria or prevent them from
growing and dividing and targeting and
there's a whole targeting issue so but
then those same molecules have to have
properties that that are amenable to
being drugs so you know they can't be
toxic to all cells especially not the
host and they have to be soluble enough
to deliver so one of the great
difficulties in drug discovery as are
the properties of your molecules so I
think that many people who did medicinal
chemistry work both at Novartis and
other companies would probably agree
that the small molecules that humanity
searches through when looking for drugs
not just anti and
but all kinds tended to be not
necessarily the types of molecules we
would want they tend to be flat and
greasy there's a great paper called
escape from the flatlands talking about
the chemical flatlands and enzymes do
chemistry that often do chemistry that
humans have a hard time doing and and
these enzymes are encoded by DNA and you
know they have evolved in deep time in
nature and and so this enzymology sort
of allows it mapped to a whole universe
of chemistry some of which we know a lot
of which we probably don't know and that
chemistry has properties that makes the
molecules sort of the opposite of being
flat and greasy that makes them in many
ways more drug-like so we're and to be
more specific to have a certain
molecular shape so a three-dimensional
shape and that type of chemistry in
general is hard for humans to do
specifically anyway but it's easy for
enzymes to do because they've evolved to
do specific chemistry and they don't
typically cause side reactions and and
mixtures so that was really what got me
interested in synthetic biology as a
vehicle to find new chemistry to drug
targets that we've had difficulty we
being humanity has had difficulty
targeting and and that's sort of the
central thesis - Tirra Biosciences where
I am now is can we use small-scale
transcription and translation reactions
so reactions that take DNA and that DNA
is turned into RNA and that RNA is
encoding protein can we can we take
protein that's encoded by DNA that we
put into these reactions and can those
proteins do chemistry as enzymes that
allows us to find new molecular entities
so we're doing a few different things
we're discovering new enzymes and this
is called functional genomics and then
when we mix together groups of enzymes
they do chemistry and our long-term goal
is to find new chemistry in the
therapeutic space and so
it's it's really just an evolution of
what I started with
but it's addressing this unmet problem
unmet need I think in in biopharma
discovery which are small molecules the
non antibiotic antibodies the non
biologics
that have properties that are different
than what we typically have in our small
molecule libraries and I think nature is
full of these and the question is can we
use this platform to discover them and
and you know how can we make sense of
what we found yeah okay so there's a
massive amount of evolution that's
happened three nine billion years
especially of bacterial evolution and
that gives us a a huge catalogue of
evolution to look through and to see
exactly what sorts of evolutionary
strategies exist for us to be able to
take from what molecular production
systems occur in evolution for us to be
able to take and apply to our health
care or agriculture etc and we have that
image to Ron that will that we can bring
up so this is you guys leveraging
computation and automation into these
these tiny little like micro factories
that are then brewing up the the
different seeing how the molecules are
are affecting what your teach teachers
about this but what's so to be clear for
the viewers these are droplets that
contain food coloring and water because
most of most of our reactions are clear
and someone once asked me what I did and
I said well how deeply do you want me to
describe it and I said it's indirectly
observing things that happen when I mix
some small volumes of clear liquid with
other small volumes of clear liquid and
if you explain it that way people think
you're crazy yeah but this is for
artistic effect but but yes in
seriousness what we do is we we make we
make these sort of cell-free factories
and we make them by grinding up cells
separating their components out so we
take you know living cells so they can
be bacteria they can be other things
we grind them up so they're no longer
living they'll no longer have that
separation between you know external
environment and internal environment but
we do so in a way that preserves their
ability to take DNA that we put in you
know that we addict you know exogenously
and make RNA from that that DNA and then
make proteins from that RNA and there's
a few interesting there's a few reasons
why this is this is interesting and why
these self Rieff you know factories if
you want to call them that are helpful
one reason is that we can add whatever
we want to the reaction and this is
allows us to prototype what might be
called unnatural natural chemistry
so sometimes enzymes can use can act on
molecules that they wouldn't normally
see in nature but we can add those
molecules from the outside to our
reactions because they're open we don't
have to get them into an organism the
other thing is that we can print pieces
of DNA and we can layer many of those
inside one of these reactions also
because they're open so we can we can
mix and match which proteins were making
and and introduce diversity in the
products of those enzymes by doing that
the other thing that's really important
and it's subtle but it bears repeating
is that because these are not living
organisms but they maintain this ability
to make proteins from you know DNA we
are able to discover enzymes that might
be toxic to the host so if you
engineered yeast or bacteria to make a
certain enzyme and many companies do
this and it's it's a really good way to
discover biochemistry what you don't
find is you don't find the enzymes that
their mere expression in the host makes
them toxic and so that's sort of like a
dark dark area of the enzymatic space of
biochemistry that is not easy to uncover
if you say take a gene from algae that
you've gotten from
Molecular bioprospecting of the oceans
for instance and you put that into
e.coli and you say okay can e coli make
this gene and is it functional sometimes
the answer is yes but sometimes you just
don't get anything or the e.coli die
because just the expression of that gene
is bad for them so because we don't have
any any we compare we preserve some
components of the living system but it's
really not alive and thus you know it
doesn't have a way of you know kicking
out a plasmid or slowing down its growth
in response to making something toxic
this allows us to uncover things you
wouldn't normally see and so you know
this is a hypothesis we're still in the
process of testing this but we think
that this will allow us to prospect in
areas where some other platforms can't
and of course as a business model it's
it's an experiment to you know will this
be will this be valuable to the
synthetic biology world is sort of a
question that as a company we're testing
by our very work yeah yeah D linking
this all the way let's see if I can take
some steps all the way back to where you
were initially teaching us about what
you were discovering when you got into
the the first sort of labs where you
were where you're putting like blood
samples into centrifuges and stuff so
and then bring it up all the way here so
when when you're taking like blood and
putting it in a centrifuge centrifuges
the main producers aluminum right of
centrifuges oh you're thinking about
sequences sequence sequencers yeah so so
centrifuges just spin things back yeah
and there's there's many producers of
those and that that work was not very
scientific it was more procedural it was
separate yes so yes so here's where I'm
interested okay this is what this is
kind of what I want to break down so
Illumina is a main is doing the newest
gen sequencing yep and they do that
through a process of breaking down the
double helix and writing up the
nucleotides somehow they do that well
leave it at that yeah
that'll centrifuges are spinning around
things like blood and then making it so
that you can take a specific part of the
blood and go in sample precisely okay
so then now when you're doing things
like you know you're talking earlier
about about about you take like an
actual a bacterial cell and you're
you're kind of you're giving this
example of you know you're teaching me
initially when you're about about how
DNA and RNA and proteins that this
process is kind of all happening in a
chaos theory way it's not necessarily
step two step two step at a time they're
all influencing each other at the same
time and yes do you I've uh okay well we
learn it we learn it in a step to step
way learning assembly but they're
constantly in in real living organisms
it's much different I gave a talk that
you attended yes called something along
the lines of DNA is not computer code
and I think this is an important point
so yes DNA is a template for RNA which
you can think of as a temporary message
which is a template for making proteins
and but really it's not one-to-one
mapping and there's and so I think
that's what you're referring to yes yes
correct and then the when what is what's
encoded in the DNA is then the RNA will
will take what's encoded in the DNA and
act as a messenger to the ribosome yeah
and then the ribosome will take that
message and then make a protein yes and
then the protein is an enzyme sometimes
it's an enzyme sometimes it's a
structural component of a cell so an
enzyme is a protein that catalyzes
chemistry catalyzes further chemistry
and some usually proteins are enzymes
because they want to catalyze something
often but they're they can be very often
structural components of cells B cells
have structure and so there's proteins
that are just they're literally
structural building
box so not all of them catalyze okay
so now we take what you're describing
earlier about taking a single cell or
cells and you're like you're kind of
like running them yeah you grind them up
however you buy different lesser well
how do you grind up the cell first well
or lyse the cells yeah we do it a number
of different ways sometimes just by
putting them under high pressure and
squeezing them through a small aperture
so then you have shear forces that yeah
them a particle apart no but the cell
can't actually it's not it's not living
anymore at that point at that point it's
not alive but you can take the DNA RNA
ribosomes protein enzymes within it and
take those and then bring them into
these yes and then you can add your own
DNA exogenous DNA exactly and then now
you're saying okay mixture do do
chemistry for us very for us but if it's
toxic to a cell that's living we might
still see it in those reactions where we
wouldn't see it necessarily in a cell so
that's it's we've lost some of the
regulatory machinery yeah that cells
used to keep themselves happy okay but
then you'd have to retest in in the
organism okay because something may end
up being non-toxic here but toxic in the
environment so so the here we use this
for rapid prototyping and yes rapidly
because there's what this looks like a
thousand or of these little vectors yeah
so and we can do these in in you know
five micro liter and smaller volumes so
it's you know smaller than a droplet
that would come out of say a medicine
dropper 5 microliters so and and it's
you know so it's a way we can we can do
many experiments quickly and then you
imagine there's a potentially really
interesting data back end on that yeah
because we know what DNA sequences we
put in we know other things we've done
to these reactions so and because the
experiments are well control
and and are done in you know multiples
and and you know in proximity to each
other and with with many things
controlled we can learn things about
what our determinants of proteins
function so for instance you know from
the sequence we can route we can test
many many sequences to say you know oh
in this sequence base this portion of it
encodes you know functional acyl
transferase is a certain type of enzyme
but maybe this actually does something
different and so we can quickly test
those hypotheses and that's that's on
the route to using these mixtures to
make drug like molecules is is
understanding what the enzymes actually
do because you can predict
computationally and that that's one of
the things that's driven forward
synthetic biology is the ability to look
at a protein sequence that's encoded or
a DNA sequence figure out what protein
that might encode and if that proteins
an enzyme predict what chemistry it
might do but still a large amount of
that is not known so there's a really a
big need to empirically test these
hypotheses and our platform is one way
of doing it yes now why would you then
not take just a bunch of why do you why
do you do the grinding a process and put
it into these five micro liter
containers rather than maybe just have
cells themselves and then put your DNA
in the cell environment so yeah so so
people do that yeah but one thing is is
that how you assemble the DNA that goes
in those organisms is often a bit more
complicated than what we do often people
put say a replicating plasmid into say
an e coli and our plasmid is a piece of
circular DNA copies of which can be made
and it's used to drive expression and as
cells divide if they it's a bacteria the
daughter cells get copies of this this
plasmid and you know one can you know
make knock ins - you know genomic DNA
and things like that with your dad any
DNA
you want to when the cells grinded up
versus when it's in it's yeah it's
generally easier because we don't have
to play tricks to get it into the cell
plate well and I wouldn't call them the
tricks our standard in the field there
was nothing weird about it but it it it
it takes that layer of complexity out
and it also takes out the layer of
complexity where what you've put into
the cells makes the cells not happy for
some reason or another oh and then they
either don't make what you want them to
make or they die or push out the
exogenous DNA easier in the non
crushed-up environment yeah if they're
if they're a living organism they'll do
whatever they have to to make themselves
as fit as possible but here we don't you
know our reactions aren't evolving
they're just doing their transcription
and translation and other chemistry too
now okay now there's a couple questions
that came in my mind okay first question
is how do you decide what exogenous DNA
you're adding to these first question
the second question is how the hell do
you actually compute what's happening
inside of these so there's a those are
both great questions so when what we
decide to put in can really be any sort
of hypothesis we want to test so I'll
give you an example maybe we have a
whole class of enzymes called cytochrome
p450s so there there are enzymes that do
a particular type of chemistry and we
have a panel of them that we we know
their sequences because they've been
published or they're they're from
organisms that have been sequenced by
someone somewhere and we want to test
that whole panel of enzymes each
individually for their ability to do
something to a molecule that we're
interested in so we put the DNA encoding
those enzymes one piece of DNA for one
enzyme into each reaction and then we
have the small molecule that we're
interested in in each reaction and then
on the back end you know we let the
reaction run we have a way that we can
determine if we've made RNA message and
then depending on how we set it up
we can determine if we've made the
protein that we're interested in because
only new proteins that got made it that
get made in these reactions will be
tracked and so we can differentiate
between what's new that's been made
versus what came along with the cells
okay and then and then if we've made our
small molecule or changed our small
molecule the back end would look like
liquid chromatography or mass
spectrometry or all these quantitative
ways to characterize small molecules
okay so let me see if I can guess right
so you're you have you already know that
and the enzymes chemistry that's
happening what's predicted chemistry the
predicted chemistry that's happened so
you have a predicted chemistry then you
add a molecule then you're adding
something into the different enzymes
that depends Iams and then your your
when your computationally mapping what's
happening in each one of the experiments
you're logging only what the novel
protein yeah the new proteins that are
made we can see you can see those and
then you and then somehow you turn goo
into well sort of to knowledge well
right now right now it's a it's actually
an exercise in data handling and you
know well because it gets really
complicated you have to track everything
that's going into each reaction track
what's going on in that reaction and
then track your readout at the end which
will be specific often for what you're
trying to make so there's general
learnings that we get from every
reaction we're on which is how well and
how much of our protein of interest that
we're trying to make in that given
reaction that enzyme of interest how
much of it are we able to make relative
to its cousins or
orthologues that we're testing but on
the other side of it what small
molecules or what what chemistry those
enzymes are doing you know that readout
will be different from class of enzyme
to class of enzyme so it's all these
layers of data and we think that there's
interesting and non-obvious things to
learn you know because if you take the
massive catalog of enzymes and somatic
chem
Street that occurs and then whatever
small tiny tiny percent that we
understand is probably less than 1% of
all of it that we actually get and then
we're trying to understand what the
other 99% does and then apply that to
agriculture and healthcare exactly that
that's very exciting that that's the
stuff that also gets me like it gets me
salivating about what biology knows that
like we don't know and how we can apply
that to our lives and that's that's
exactly $20 opportunity that exists but
to be clear it isn't easy
and on even the big players you know
there's big players in the field who've
done really amazing work
ginko bio works and zymogen and amorous
and you know a lot of the companies that
have pushed the molecular discovery in
synthetic biology forward have been
doing it in organism and we hope to add
to that toolbox that they've they've
started we hope to add cell-free
prototyping and you know see where we
can go with that in terms of prospecting
for new chemical matter so it's but but
technically there's there's engineering
challenges there's data handling
challenges and biology is hard because
it's unpredictable so yeah yeah and then
you have to replicate this because yet
works one time you want to replicate it
again - exactly not the same result and
so this is the you know this kind of
segues us into what we want to talk
about next but I just find it
interesting that on one side it's called
you know you use cells for discovery
yeah on the other side you don't use
cells but you actually took cells and
blended them up and use their components
your components but they're dead and
then yeah it's kind of it's funny the
cell-free discovery okay so I mean let's
segue then so we're talking about this
in a fascinating way right now where you
know if you come out if your copy if
your if your computations producing your
test is producing a certain computation
and you're read out as something and
you're like aha interesting then what
you have to do is you have to do that
again yep because you want to verify if
you verify three four twenty times
you're like okay we can probably say
with like 99
percent accuracy this is right and so
that's how you do science that's the
scientific method that is testing your
hypothesis over and over again and we've
seen so many instances where this
foundation of knowledge you're very
passionate about this I'm excited to
talk about this foundation of scientific
literature and knowledge that we've
built on has these like little cracks
and they're kind of like sometimes this
the the way that we handle academia
isn't in the most conducive way so teach
us about the way that you want to
inspire people to rewrite the scientific
playbook and rewrite the incentives
because I love this so it's it's one of
its one of motivations and so if you
view science as an ecosystem you have
many different players you have
universities you have private companies
you have not-for-profit Institute's and
NGO type organizations and and a lot of
things in between and you have amateur
scientists who are operating on their
own or in groups and all of this all
this is really good but they all have
different strengths and weaknesses and
have different motives and in academia
especially in academic science I think
the motive is often priority so if you
want your grants to be funded you have
to have a paper that shows that you are
the first to describe something and I
feel that that even without ill intent
that tends to motivate people to
oversell what they've discovered and
maybe not be as careful about
reproducing it before they publish it as
they should and then companies like
Novartis where I worked and and
companies like Terra Biosciences where I
currently work and other academic labs
and people all over the place will
sometimes depend on that literature to
guide them and won't be able to
reproduce the data and no one really has
put a number to this to my knowledge
though I may be wrong but I think it
represents a huge opportunity costs in
time and money and I really think that
we should incentivize people in academia
to publish derivative works as well as
novel ones where those derivative works
show within them that a whole other
study can be reproduce
and and there's movements to do this and
I think open access publishing in
general is is a good thing you know most
of the science the the basic research
done in the u.s. anyway is funded by the
public in you know one form or another
and so I think that it's really key that
publicly funded science be available to
the public and be as reproducible as
possible because there's huge sections
of the economy that depend upon that and
and then then there's gets to education
you know I I mean I won't be shy about
it I think that academic education in
education in the sciences is a pyramid
scheme
and again it's it is a pyramid scheme
it's not because of ill intent but yeah
the way the funding model works is if
you're a faculty member and you want to
keep the grants coming in you need
people to do the research that makes the
papers that help make the case for your
grants and so the model works when
there's more trainees than there are
terminal people at the top of the
pyramid professors or Dean's and so you
see this huge number of postdoctoral
fellows and graduate students being
trained for a very small number of
professorships that are open in any
given year and it's a matter of
narrative which i think is really
important and we need to change in
science that becoming a research
professor is not the only thing that you
can do that training on one hand and on
the other hand can we be more efficient
about how we educate and train
scientists and i know education and
training are actually a bit divergent
but you know on one hand can we train
scientists who be passionate about their
science at the level of philosophy which
a PhD would imply but doesn't often you
know confer and on the other hand can we
train people to do what they need to in
the laboratory and have touched
different techniques to push specific
research forward and I just really think
we I think rethinking that is really
important and that's why I'm involved
among other things with Indy bio because
I think that if I if I could go back
again if I was finishing grad school
and even though I had a good experience
in my postdoc I would definitely
probably go to a startup accelerator or
incubator of some sort just because it's
you learn a lot that way and it's in
many ways comparable to doing a post
doctoral yeah you know fellowship so I
think we need to to incentivize
reproducible research and academia and
and in an industry it's sort of
different like within your own company
with it's essential that people can
reproduce work and so if anything the
motivation goes a bit far the opposite
direction is there's an emphasis on you
know reproducible protocols but then
there's less bandwidth to do novel work
so I think that what academia is good at
and what industry is good at in science
are not always the same thing they're
often the same thing but not always and
for a healthy ecosystem you need both to
be you know everything to be healthy so
you know we need to rethink you know can
we train graduate students in the
sciences with a funding mechanism that
doesn't require a pyramid scheme to make
it work and you know can we build
bridges to industry and I think you know
that's being done but can we think of
creative ways to train people and
educate people in the sciences that
don't take all of their 20s and you know
don't end the mole and them in a postdoc
where they you know get paid like 40k a
year regardless of where they live and
do their research and then are starting
their career and they're you know early
to late 30s doing something after that
so I really think we need to be more
respectful of students time yes and and
then you know the other thing is this is
a better way to for the edge of
knowledge to be explored more
effectively reproduce the results
incentivize that as well as when you're
at the edge of knowledge how do you get
the kids in there in there even in their
teens to start kind of playing around at
that edge of knowledge with the right
mentors and with the right strategies
and then get them to the point where
you're not in your mid-30s before you're
even starting to dabble potential
in industry related progress and and you
know and it's also it ties into how we
communicate science to the public I mean
the public by and large doesn't realize
one of my colleagues once called the
postdoc postdoc apocalypse postdoc
ellipse and you know that you know this
just isn't generally I think known about
and it should be discussed because this
comes at a great cost to human potential
but I think the other the other thing to
talk about and what I'm personally
interested is changing the narrative of
science so scientists are often
portrayed a certain way in the media a
certain way in literature and I really
yeah and just so passionately been
aiming to push the things that we have
around us these brilliant devices what
we're using right now to stream the the
vehicles that were driving the the
medicines that we get at the healthcare
institutions etc this is all aspects of
brilliant scientific burdens of geniuses
that people have taken on to pursue but
an important point of that is almost all
those discoveries were team efforts
there were and and I think exactly and I
think we have to get away from this idea
of a heroic scientist doing heroic
research in the lab that opens up a
whole field I mean it sometimes happens
but but it's really better to think of
it as a team exercise and then if you
think of it in that way one should ask
myself well how cognitively diverse our
scientists really are we losing people
from the field who our discoveries and
our creativity would be better for them
but maybe their personalities and minds
work differently than what we're
selected for in in science so so to get
through you know a PhD in biochemistry
you have to be willing to live on a lot
of ramen noodles and you know there's a
certain selective pressure right because
people will say screw this I'm going to
go get a job in finance or I'm going to
do something that allows me to you know
be able to travel on weekends or you
know things of that sort so it selects
for a certain type of person the current
way we're doing it and what I'd like to
outside of my work with tiara and with
some friends and colleagues we started a
bio captivate a not-for-profit that
we're going to we're in the process of
launching to sort of bring these
conversations to broader discussion is
how do we how do we how do we nurture
cognitive diversity in the sciences and
and how do we how do we find inspiration
at for instance the intersection of art
and science the arts and the sciences
which are not in opposition but in fact
should work together and and so anyway
this is this is what I'm interested in
beyond just biochemistry and I think
that there's an important place for that
I love it and give me your one thought
because we'll have to have you back to
talk more about an update on tear as
well as more on the survey found Asian
knowledge but give me your thought on
how to best you know we find ourselves
like again back to the beginning of
stewards of Earth a billion of us
exponential technology we evolved so
quickly what is the ideal
well-functioning Republic for you in the
US or a species like what would be some
of these principles you're such a first
principles thinker well I mean I think
that this freedom to you know within
certain parameters live life how one
wants to use one's time how one wants to
especially to be given permission
permission to be creative yeah I think
that this is really important and I
think that a responsibility for society
also should temper that that
individualistic impulse so I think that
we should individuals should have a
great freedom to explore to be creative
but that at the same time we recognize
certain principles that have to be
upheld for the good of everyone as a
group and I mean I think you know
obviously certain you know public order
and
and you know freedom of speech and and
you know fair legal processes are all
important but I really think one thing
that that I fear is slipping that that
an ideal Republic would have would be
the ability of any child no matter if
they were born wealthy or you know at
the lowest end of the spectrum of you
know family wealth that that society
might have to have equal access to the
same quality of education that is a man
and if they choose to take advantage of
it and they should be encouraged to I
think we really have to do that because
think of who we might be losing we are
losing so many brilliant things just
because they weren't in the right place
to go that and so to me
like that's really important to me too
that's why that's why you know we're on
we're on that same wave like they're I'm
glad you said that that people born into
the world to get to pass their time how
they so choose to absolutely and also
that equality of opportunity for people
to pursue whatever they want with their
time with their native potential so at
least if the baseline is there forever
exact pursue okay we'll unpack that more
student okay the cue quick questions on
the way this is simulation are we in the
simulation oh I don't know not enough
data give me your best imagination on if
we're in a simulation makes me think of
like the brain and the VAT type
experiment oh I don't know well then how
do you explain dreams yeah yeah that's
right
are those simulations inside a
simulation I don't know it's a it's a
pretty hard hypothesis to test right
it's a good one to poke with the
scientific probe you're kind of running
little simulations in all of your little
tests we are that are happening that's
interesting that's how we like to think
about it as well okay last question sure
what's the most beautiful thing in the
world the most beautiful thing in the
world you know I think the most
beautiful thing in the world
is honestly you know waking up wherever
you are and knowing that you're going to
have another day that's going to be
different than the last
I think if everything was the same it
would be boring and I think that that
there was just a there's a beauty and in
the unknown and and in possibilities so
I think yeah the most beautiful thing
are the possibilities that one might see
that's great that's a good answer I like
that one a lot too all right this has
been such a pleasure I feel like that I
was reading myself to at least the first
day of first grade nice - thank you for
having me really appreciate it yeah this
has been such a pleasure really
appreciate keep up all the great work
with tiara Biosciences and everything
else bio captivate everyone check out
the links below to Lewis his work also
follow us on twitter follow me on
linkedin as well go check out his work
also huge shout out to ron vargas for
producing a directing major thank you
would greatly appreciate you everyone
give us your thoughts in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you on the
topics that we talked about how can you
pursue the front to your synthetic
biology as well yourselves go and crack
at that edge go and build on it everyone
also support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you love that you
want to see succeed go and support them
all our links are below keep supporting
them in your communities also build the
future manifest your dreams into the
world everyone inspire others in your
communities and around the world we love
you so much and we will see you soon
peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]